herr n a sie haben während 15 jahren
ganz unterschiedliche substanzen
ausprobiert so ziemlich alles was es
gibt oder gab sie haben
tollkirsche ausprobiert schmerzmittel
lsd oder pilze und schlussendlich dann
auch heroin sie waren am platzspitz sie
haben auch den letzten miterlebt in der
stadt zürich und dann auch die
schließung des letzten sie waren 14 auf
das ganze angefangen hat mögen sie sich
erinnern das hat dann auch den einstieg
verursacht der einstieg war oder die
motivation für den anstieg war die suche
ich hatte das gefühl da ist noch eine
eine lehre und durch literatur durch
freundeskreis dachte ich damals mit 14
frauen mit psychedelic sei das zufügen
und wie oft aus diesen weg haben sie
gedacht das ist der richtige weg
lange zeit oder schon bald nicht mehr es
war immer der richtige weg für die paar
stunden anhielt und am nächsten tag oder
in dieser nächsten tag verlassen und man
vergisst das ist verblasst und man denkt
dann okay beim nächsten nächsten
erfahrung dann stellt sich die weisheit
oder die erfüllung ein
und das stimmt zum teil für die zeit des
rausches irgendwo habe ich gelesen dass
sie gesagt haben mein größter rausch war
es nüchtern zu lernen
hier muss ich diesen satz verstehen ich
habe 15 jahre lang meine wahrnehmung
eine denkprozesse mit substanzen
beeinflusst und zwar 15 jahre ohne einen
tag nüchtern und das aufwachen aus
diesem rausch oder dass diese betreuung
zum großen teil war für mich ein
elementares erlebnis also heute dass es
jetzt doch schon 16 jahre her noch heute
ist jeder morgen bin ich auf regen
nämlich gerüchte so wahrnehmen wie sie
sind und nicht so sehr wie es ist oder
wie es mein körper wahrnehmen kann
etwas wofür ich dankbar bin dass wir
viel viel spaß macht mich mit
befriedigung für herscheid
sie sind arzt und wie schon gesagt habe
sie erforschen die wirkung von
psychedelischen substanzen sind auch ein
stückweit begeistert von den
möglichkeiten dieser neuen substanzen in
der psychiatrie
wenn sie jetzt als arzt diese geschichte
hören müssen sie dann nicht in erster
linie sagen hände weg von jeglichen
rauschmitteln
ja das stimmt mich natürlich betroffen
ist eine geschichte die ich aufhöre
als psychiater und ich würde sagen ein
rauschmittel ist nicht per se gut oder
schlecht sondern es kommt immer auf den
kontext an auf die absicht an mit der es
angenommen wird
gerade in der medizin sind ja viele
medikamente für uns sehr wertvoll
beispielsweise opiate zur
schmerzbehandlung oder benzodiazepine
zum beruhigen in der psychiatrie die
wären eigentlich gar nicht mehr
wegzudenken
trotzdem werden sie in anderen kontexten
als rauschmittel missbraucht
ich glaube dass psychedelic falls wir
wirklich in wissenschaftlichen
wirkungsnachweis erbringen könnten in
zukunft wieder den status von
medikamenten bekommen können also wieder
so wie im einspieler vorhin wie das herr
hoffmann damals eigentlich gedacht hatte
nicht die vision von albert hofmann
sofern es uns gelingt tatsächlich auch
zu zeigen dass sie effekte
haben im rahmen einer psychotherapie und
vergleichbar oder vielleicht auch besser
wirken als bisherige medikamente über in
der psychiatrie haben
es ist mir kurz den begriff klären
psychedelic k vielleicht können sie kurz
fragen was zeit zu dieser klasse
psychedelischer sind substanzen die das
bewusstsein verändern erweitern da
gehört klassischerweise lsd dazu
der wirkstoff der magic mushrooms aber
auch meskalin für die zaubertinte sagen
pilze genau das wären so typische
vertreter dieser substanzklassen die
auch jetzt in der forschung wieder
intensiver untersucht werden kann
hiervon versöhnlich verschiedenen
substanzen geredet von unterschiedlichen
wirkungen von unterschiedlichen
einsatzmöglichkeiten
können sie beschreiben die fühlt sich
einen heroin rausch an jetzt im
vergleich zu sagen die zauber pilzen die
man einnimmt
sie haben ja das meiste ausprobiert das
sind das in welten die psyche regel
haben es karin oder lsd die substanz
macht auch nicht so ein wahnsinniger
unterschied verändert wirklich auch die
wahrnehmung also die die sinnliche
wahrnehmung tastsinn geruch sind die
optischen eindrücke und kombiniert das
mit einem sehr intensiven empfinden auch
sehr anstrengend also es ist es kann im
besten falle sehr bereichernd sein in
der erfahrung man sieht sachen man sieht
vielleicht auch zusammenhänge ob die
dann da sind wird man wieder aufmacht
oder nicht ist was anderes aber es kann
sehr befriedigend sein und bei den
opiaten
das ist erinnert immer diesen großen
schweren namen und man hatte man die das
gefühl von diesem großen
ergebnis und das gefährliche am heroin
rasch ist dass er nicht spektakulär ist
es ist nicht so dass etwas wahnsinnig
großes nach ihm kommt sondern es ist so
dass jeglicher schmerz verschwindet und
die absenz von jeglichem schmerz ist
eben nicht spektakulär von unheimlich
trösten hat ja auch damit zu tun dass
sozusagen eine heroin einnahme dann oft
gegen reagiert auf eine sucht die sich
bereits entwickelt hat währenddessen ein
lsd trip nicht unbedingt vorher eine
sucht vorliegen muss wenn ich vielleicht
noch haben aber diesen punkt bleiben sie
auch psychiater sie führen entsprechende
studien durch was genau machen sie haben
mir im vorfeld gesagt viele studierende
melden sich bei ihm viele waren bei den
versuchen mitmachen was genau erlebt man
denn wenn man sich bei ihnen melden bei
so einer studie mit machen also
grundsätzlich geht es uns darum die
wirkmechanismen dieser substanzen besser
zu untersuchen das heißt wir untersuchen
frauen gesunden versuchspersonen
beispielsweise mit magnetresonanz
tomographie nachdem sie nimmt sich
aktive substanz zu sich genommen haben
wir interessieren uns wie das denken
verändert wird die wahrnehmung braucht
emotionale prozesse weil wir uns dadurch
erhoffen besser zu verstehen wie diese
substanzen auch beispielsweise in einer
psychotherapie eingesetzt werden können
und da bestimmte gehirnveränderungen
bringen können die patienten dazu führen
dass sie besser lernen oder fortschritte
machen können im rahmen einer
psychotherapie oder bestimmte defizite
beispielsweise auszugleichen im
emotionalen oder im sozialen bereich
man hört manchmal dass ein lsd-trip ein
begleiteter lsd trip unter umständen
zehn jahre psychotherapie ersparen
können
das ist natürlich eine sehr plakative
bemerkung das würde ich sehr stark in
frage stellen sich viele kassen keine
unter drogen sie können sich das so
vorstellen wenn sie zum
dentalhygienikerin dann sieht das gebiss
am nächsten tag auch blitzblank aus aber
wenn sie nicht zähne putzen dann
verblasster effekt relativ schnell
wieder und bei den psychedelic auf das
genauso
ich sehe den wert vor allem in der
einbettung in eine psychotherapie das
heißt patienten sollten lernen wirklich
nicht bewusstseins kompetenz aufzubauen
um die effekte von psychedelic auch
nachhaltig im leben stabilisieren zu
lernen wie sehen sie das
drogen statt psychotherapie also diese
idee der trieb sozusagen der mir alles
bewusst macht mir alles auf dem tablett
serviert dass ich immer schon wissen
wollte über mich selbst meine geschichte
ich denke es ist wirklich eine frage der
persönlichkeit
ich denke dieses schnelle diese diese
schnelle selbsterkenntnis die wird sich
nicht einstellen
es gibt wie keine abkürzung
die arbeit am eigenen ich es gibt keine
es gibt keinen schnellen oder leichten
weg ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen
dass es in schwierigen situationen oder
auch im verfahren in einem verfahren
oder sagten ich als öffner dienen kann
und da bin ich bei meinen mit ghost
eingebettet in eine therapie begleitet
kann man in diese richtung arbeiten
es ist auch ein bisschen einbrecher
heißen oder ein stemmeisen für die
situation wo man anders nicht
weiterkommt es ist mir beide sehr
vorsichtig das ist wahrscheinlich dem
thema auch angebracht es gibt viele
beispiele in denen trips in horrortrips
geändert haben die haben mein spieler
schon gesehen
es kann so zu suizidversuchen es gibt
psychosen die ausgelöst werden können
durch entsprechende substanzen
trotzdem würde ich gerne micro polen
noch erwähnen ein journalist der dieses
buch geschrieben hat verändere dein
bewusstsein sorgt gerade rund um den
erdball für furore ist im januar auf
deutsch erschienen und er führt die
psychiatrie ließe sich komplett
verändern wenn wir beginnen würden
psychedelische substanzen gezielt
einzusetzen
schon ein bisschen ihre position oder
herr schaidinger
ich denke es könnte schon gewissermaßen
zu einem paradigmenwechsel beitragen
weil die bisherigen psychopharmaka die
wir haben was ihren immer noch auf
wirkmechanismen aus den 50er 60er jahren
und dienen ja vor augen dazu symptome zu
substituieren das heißt eine depression
beispielsweise mit antidepressiva zu
behandeln die stimmung zu heben indem
chronisch jeden tag das serotonin im
gehirn angeregt wird während die
psychedelic eigentlich nur wenige male
verabreicht werden und er seine form von
transformations- passierte therapie sind
das heißt im idealfall lernt die person
etwas neues dazu sich neu im bewusstsein
auszurichten und ist dann nicht
angewiesen täglich zum beispiel
medikamente ein
also keine abkürzung aber so ein kleiner
turbo booster dazwischen könnte man so
sagen